hi I'm Erik Bosse and Pixar's Toy Story
boar has released a new teaser trailer
introducing us to 40 the spork and
giving us some major clues about the
movie's plot we can't just leave these
guys things so long partner we need
another good cry so far we just have
this teaser plus another reaction video
with ducky and bunny but between these
two clips there's actually a lot of big
details revealed so let's break them all
down an spoiler warning in case any of
these predictions end up being too right
and they ruin your life okay let's watch
the first clip of the teaser we were
looking at the usual suspect woody buzz
Jesse the whole gang all in some kind of
joyful dance messes this probably isn't
gonna be in the actual movie by the way
what's most interesting is the music
choice this is Joni Mitchell's both
sides now it's one of those meaningful
folk pop songs ever it's it's actually a
really popular song selection for movies
that you might have seen loved actually
read of Terry the movie Steve Jobs
actually broke down the lyrics meaning
and structure the whole film around the
song basically Mitchell brings up three
subjects clouds love and life with each
verse reflecting how her perspective on
these things shifted from a romantic
dreamy view to a realistic regretful one
and how in the end she realizes she
doesn't really understand these
illusions at all
I warned yet it's deep at first this
song just seems like a great choice
because of the first subject clouds it
reflects the cloud wallpaper of the
iconic opening and closing image of the
first three Toy Story movies but I'll
get to how this deeper meaning could
connect to this movie story in a bit
okay fast-forward in through the rest of
the gang mr. Potato Head mrs. Potato
Head Rex ham and aliens slinky dog and
we meet the new guy
[Music]
okay so this guy is for key he's a spork
according to the movie synopsis Bonnie
remember the girl Andy left his toys
with has brought to this reluctant new
homemade toy into a room which will lead
to a road trip adventure porky is voiced
by Tony Hale Buster from Arrested
Development and Gary from veep 4 he's a
plastic spork with googly eyes pipe
cleaner arms and popsicle stick feet
with the rainbow sticker on one of them
the movie's director Josh coolly said
that the movie will explore the
existential crisis of toys that are made
out of other objects like porky will
want to fulfill his purpose as a spork
but he also has this new toy purpose
that's thrust upon him now we should
remind ourselves that thought
experiments that extrapolate too far can
be a dangerous game when it comes to the
Pixar universe we definitely had made
this mistake with cars and if we want to
see the dark horrors of the daily lives
of inanimate objects we already have the
movie sausage party for that instead it
looks like forky will undergo a lighter
trauma of purpose like do I exist to
deliver food both solid and liquid forms
to a person's mouth or do I exist to be
a child's plaything you can imagine how
shocking it would be to go from being
licks to being a thing with a real
identity it does make one wonder when an
object becomes a toy with sentience
like maybe this happened the moment
Bonnie put eyes on it I don't know for
me googly eyes could give anything a
soul my guess is for key came to life
the moment Bonnie named him and played
with him the first time and for he's not
the first time this happened ham was not
really a toy to begin with his function
was a piggy bank and he made him a toy
when he picked him up to play with him
same goes for Bo Peep she wasn't really
a toy she was part of like a porcelain
lamp and Andy Bree appropriated her as a
love interest for woody and his games
and I'm thinking that the deeper meaning
of both sides now could apply to woody
and the gangs shift in perspective in
their mentor relationship with Porky
like in the first movie Woody and Buzz
were discovering their purposes toys for
a child and now they're on the other
side helping a new object understand
what it means to be there for a kid and
I gotta warn you this story sounds like
it's gonna hit pretty hard Tom Hanks
described the movies ending as a moment
in history and Tim Allen said the last
scene was so emotionally could even get
through it like if these dudes or
softies are they're gonna need to give
out some free hugs outside the movie
theaters now a day after this teaser
came out Pixar
least another clip featuring two more
toys ducky and bunny voiced by
keegan-michael key and Jordan Peele
reacting into the Toy Story news in a
carnival booth hey guys you got it all
wrong
it's to infinity and beyond impossible
super fun and who knows if ducky and
bunny will be part of the movie at all
or this is just another original Pixar
promo but there are a couple fun Pixar
Easter eggs in the background if you
look closely
among the hanging prizes are these
little guitar toys just like the ones we
saw in Coco also some of the plush start
oyster the exact same blue and pink
color pattern as Sulley for Monsters Inc
Pixar just can't resist resampling that
massive studio asset archive can they
but my question is do you guys think
Andy could come back into this story I
read one theory that this could all end
with Bonnie getting older and returning
the toys to Andy when he becomes a
father for a new baby Oh again partner
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow new rock stars on twitter and
instagram at new rock stars and for my
random dark thoughts about the Pixar
universe and things that make me cry
follow me on Twitter and instant area
there is one last chance to see my live
parody show infinity fan it's super
funny but like every Pixar movie it
could also make you cry but that's okay
as inside/out taught us we need sadness
it's Friday November 16th 8 p.m. Acme
theatre North Hollywood ticket info in
the description below and subscribe to
this channel for more breakdowns of
everything you love and hey somehow I
made it through this video without
crying oh no keep that Coco clip away
[Music]
[Music]